so today we have the privilege of having
as a guest dr. Craig Stadler who's
coming to us from Milwaukee
dr. Chris Adler his the editor of
Stoicism today but today he has a lot of
YouTube videos on different
philosophical topics highly recommend
watching them and he will speak with us
tonight on a black story
principle I should mention that that
Jill brought up eclecticism and although
I am editor of Stoicism today I don't
tell people that I'm an orthodox stoic
in part because I actually do draw not
only on the stoic tradition but also
very heavily on Aristotelian philosophy
and an existentialist philosophy and the
Platonic tradition as well so I you know
when they asked me to be editor I said
is it okay if I'm not you know as stoic
as the rest of you and they said that
will they'll be fine just make sure that
things go out when they're supposed to
and and they're a great bunch so what I
what I thought I would do today is you
know stereo with something very general
but I'll actually ask some questions in
just a minute
talk about stoic philosophy very briefly
how it got started
you know what what some of their key
ideas are and then I wanted to talk a
bit about modern stoicism and then we'll
jump into the the real the real meet
I've got five main practices that that
come from stoicism that I think are
useful in the workplace the theme the
reason it's the theme down the workplace
is this year the the stoic on key theme
was stoicism at work and so I've been
thinking a lot about how you apply these
these things but we could talk about it
in many other contexts what I thought we
might do is as we go through each of
these you know stoic practices I'll tell
you a bit about them give you a few
examples how you might might
clients tell you a few things that would
be good to keep in mind talk about some
of the obstacles people face in applying
them and then we could do like a short
you know sort of Q&A or discussion for
each of those and then do much longer
sort of open discussion at the end and
you know the thing that we we put
together
it's very nice this workshop guide the
the stuff that Jules doing I kind of
regret not being able to be here for it
tomorrow because it's very well put
together but there's there's a section
in there if you can take notes or thing
if your questions come to mind for
yourself and there's a few quotes I've
got all the quotes I took where from
Epictetus is enchiridion shortest one of
the most accessible works of stoic
philosophy but you can find other
similar discussions in in the other
Stoics as well so stoicism what what is
it how did it get started it's it's a
Socratic philosophy meaning that it
traces itself back to Socrates it's
actually blending together three
different strains of our traditions of
Socratic philosophy and then doing you
know sort of a synthesis and it grew
over time as well as develop developed
further into something that did become a
very coherent system doesn't cover
everything you're completely right about
that the guy who gets it started his
name is Zeno he's a Phoenician and the
story is that he was travelling with a
ship full of purple which was this dye
that was very difficult to acquire you
to get a lot of these these shellfish
and ferment them and and you know just
to get a little bit sort of like saffron
you know and his ship wrecked and all of
this went into the sea so he lost
everything he winds up going into Athens
and he's at a bookseller and he's you
know just kind of picking things up at
random and reading him he's probably
depressed as hell and he reads the
Xenophon's stories about Socrates and
he's like he'd also he'd gone to Delphi
and Delphi told him that he need
- you know connect up with with with
with these these dead people and he
realize dead authors yeah so he's
reading about Socrates and he's very
impressed by Socrates character and if
you read Xenophon Xenophon's Socrates is
this guy who's all about you know virtue
very robust it's a little different than
Plato's dialogues yes where can I find
somebody like this and so the bookseller
says we see that guy over there and
there was a croc taste the cynic was
says he's like Socrates go check him out
so he goes over there and he becomes a
student of croc taste any studies with
him and studies means wanders around
with him doing different things learning
lessons for about ten years he's not
completely faithful to krottas he also
goes and studies at the Platonic Academy
and he also studies with members of
another more obscure school the Megerian
school there's actually a story that
craw chase would like grab him by his
ear and pull him out of the the Platonic
Academy and say you know you need to
stick with the cynicism and after a
while is you know figures I guess he's
you know learned enough and he starts
teaching at a place called the stole of
pokey lay the painted porch and at first
his followers are called Zenonia n--'s
as we would you know plate plate ness
Aristotelian and after a while they
start getting named after the porch
itself so they become the stoah sort of
the way Epicureans become the garden
they're also called after Epicurus and
that's the start of the story and then
there you know there's got a lot of
great students one actually goes and
works for the Macedonian King because he
wants his II in order to come up there
he says I can't do it myself I'll send
this guy up instead there's some really
interesting accounts and diogenes
laërtius of these there's even a guy a
genies the renegade who went over to the
other schools and and you know gave up
the stoic school but the guy he passes
it down to is clay Anthes clan theis is
a boxer and he's he's a water carrier by
profession which is about as low as you
can get in in the
hierarchy but he was the guy who really
retained xenos ideas and zeno had
written some things that we don't
unfortunately possess the titles are
extremely interesting but we don't know
much more about it
clan thiis becomes the second school
lark the leader of the school and then
he in turn passes it down to cruciferous
who very prolific author engages with
other you know thinkers and argues
against them he's considered to be the
second founder of stoicism and then
after that it starts to spread out
throughout the the Greek and Roman world
the fourth guy Diogenes he goes to Rome
on an embassy I forget exactly what it
was for there were three philosophers
who went to Rome to argue some case
because by then Rome was was dominating
everything and they introduced the
Romans to this this philosophy and it
starts catching on and then you know
further and further and further along
eventually it starts to become you know
independent of the the school itself in
Athens and you find it in Rhodes you
find it you know the next person is
while dodging is Diogenes of Babylon so
he came quite a long way you find it
being taught by a bunch of people and
eventually don't actually need it there
in Athens which is good because they
lose that school
the Stoics that we have the classic
Stoics are mostly from that late Roman
period so we have mostly three guys
Seneca with quite a lot of material from
him all these letters and then some
treatises that he wrote about this and
that we have Epictetus we don't all have
well he didn't write anything actually
or he did but we don't have anything he
wrote instead he is one of his students
arias wrote down these things supposedly
eight books would be a scroll each book
is a scroll and so we have four of those
and arias also
compiled the enchiridion this short in
the hand book so we don't have a lot of
what what he you know taught
unfortunately we have even less of his
teacher whose mo Sonia srew ffice we
have a few lectures and a few fragments
and then we have Marcus Aurelius Roman
Emperor wrote down some thoughts to
himself the book is actually called to
himself
we call it the meditations and we read
it as if he's talking to us but he was
really talking to himself at the time
when he was engaged in a lot of his his
work there are a few other people we
have this guy here Cleese we've got some
fragments of his works because
unfortunately when we found some scrolls
the people who enrolled them damaged
them before they figured out how to
unroll these ancient scrolls we have
another guy arias didymus who we found
in in another thinker and I can tell you
all that that stuff later that's kind of
obscure and and far away from this so
what did they actually teach so the
Stoics thought that we should live a
life in accordance with nature that was
one of the key ideas and they said well
what does that mean so Clancy said in in
accordance with the whole of everything
and cruciferous said well yes that but
also in accordance with the true
potential of human nature what it is
that we we can be as human beings so
that's one key idea they thought of this
in terms of the virtues you know the
four cardinal virtues of wisdom justice
courage and temperance and they gave a
lot of detailed analysis to this that
you can find not so much in the stoic
writers themselves but in the people who
tell us about them like like Cicero
Cicero has some books where he goes into
considerable detail about this the later
Stoics that we have kind of presuppose
that you've you've read this stuff so
they reference it without necessarily
explaining it as much as we'd like
sometimes although Seneca is pretty good
at explaining they also said that other
things that we think of as really good
things that we ought to desire
like wealth or social position or what
other people think of us you know our
reputation those aren't really goods
they're not they're not bad things but
they're really what the Stoics called
indifference they're not things that
make us good people or make our lives
full they're useful for things they can
conduce to virtue but they can also be
used for the opposite of virtue which is
vice they can they can be used to screw
us up and and make things go wrong and
you know there there's many other facets
the Stoics developed logic and ethics
and and a physics and by that they meant
something more than what we mean by
logic logic included what we nowadays
call epistemology yeah that's right
right here on this tree I was wondering
where it was coming because I'm curious
about that sort of thing so logic you
know included how do we know things how
do we arrive at proper reasoning physics
included what we would nowadays call
philosophy of religion or theology you
know do the gods exist that they care
about us what are they what's you know
how are things made up also psychology
would fall under physics as well insofar
as were were you know physical beings
and the Stoics were materialist they
thought that this is it you know they
thought we do have souls but soul is
just a special kind of matter and it
doesn't really stick around after you
die so you know it's it's there were
different speculations maybe it sticks
around for a little while before it
breaks up they never really got very
specific about that because they're
mostly focused on how do you live now
and what should you value now and how do
you free yourself how do you live a life
that's happy and free and so you know
some of the other schools were saying
things like will maximize your pleasures
right or you need a life that's both
centered on virtue but also on friends
and enough material goods like the
Aristotelian 's were saying or it's a
life just a study the way that some of
the plaintiffs were saying and the the
Stoics said no no it's it's it's a life
that's devoted to the virtues and that
includes a life with other people right
because we are social creatures so
justice means being involved with all of
our people who are connected with us our
friends or family our community but
cultivating those was was seen as the
the primary good now
stoicism like a lot of the other schools
you know it's had its ups and downs kind
of disappears from the scene except for
little bits and pieces of it as a good
bit of it gets kind of absorbed into -
Christian thought and practices if you
look at monastic practices you'll see
clear parallels I think if you read you
know say John Cassian you'll see clear
clear parallels between what the monks
were doing in the deserts in Egypt with
their practices and what the Stoics were
doing and how they analyze things the
neoplatonist kind of sucked Stoics in as
well
and the Aristotelian 's and you know
there's people who reference them the
monks are kind of interesting in that
it's through them that we actually get
Seneca and Cicero and even epictetus to
some degree because they were the ones
who are copying these texts out and
commenting on them and thinking about
them and so they actually you know
understand them but it doesn't really
catch on again until like say the
Renaissance and the early modern period
and then you see a lot of discussion of
stoicism a lot of people taking a stand
on it sometimes seeing if there's a bad
thing
those Stoics are so prideful as poss
call you know why are the stoic so
prideful because they think that you can
you know so withdraw your desires from
the world and be this totally free being
who would not be conquered by fate or
other people or you know get it mixed in
with things the who are they to think
that they can achieve that degree of
self sufficiency
that's post college take on it he says
that they emphasize human grandeur or
greatness without understanding our
human misery although I think the Stoics
probably had knew a good bit about
misery especially epictetus was a slave
at one
in the present we can talk about modern
stoicism and I brought where did I put a
thing from here we go
stoic on 2017 which I have just come
back from I'll hand this around you can
take a look at it this is the conference
program we have a really wonderful
graphic designer working for it so I
snatched this up as quickly as I could
from the conference and I you know as
the editor of Stoicism today which is an
online essentially magazine I'm a member
of modern stoicism it's now modern
stoicism Ltd because we finally
incorporated at first it was just sort
of a loose working group and then it
grew and grew and grew and so we you
know have stoicism today we put on stoic
on every year we provide guidance for
stowe account ex events the stoic week
class which has about 6,000 people
enrolled in it at present this this time
really a huge increase that's also a
product of that and our mission is to
sort of promote modern stoicism around
the world I can tell you one place where
we haven't made much inroads is Asia but
stoic on X events also Africa stoic on X
events have been held this year on four
continents so we're kind of kind of
growing and like a lot of young
organizations we as they say scaled up
without necessarily thinking about what
we were doing because we're all just
volunteers who are interested in stoical
ideas and why is why is stoicism
catching on so much so this to the the
what I'm supposed to be talking about
here tonight right
stoicism in the workplace it's not
catching on particularly among
university professors although it
probably would be useful for quite a few
of them
speaking of somebody who knows a number
of them and how miserable they can be
and how miserable they can make other
people as well I mean there are there's
some interest in it and I know people in
the ancient philosophy community is
these are the people who work on
Aristotle these are people who work on
Stoics you know and that's that's fine
but that doesn't make much cultural
impact and you can say well it's because
you know people like Tim Ferriss and
Ryan holiday are writing these these
essentially self-help books that are
using some aspects of stoicism and and
people like that and it catches on
that's true and and and I think there's
actually that actually does a good good
thing for stoicism but it's really
because people of all walks of life are
finding ancient stoic philosophy and
sometimes they're getting it through
modern texts but a lot of times they're
actually reading epictetus and reading
Marcus Aurelius and forming study groups
and going online to these stoicism
forums they're they're finding this
actually helps them in their life and
there's good reasons to think that it
would you know one of the things where
there's a connection between stoicism
and other practices is cognitive
behavior therapy and rational emotive
behavior therapy the entire cognitive
revolution in psychotherapy essentially
comes out of a stoic ground Albert Ellis
tells us it tells them this and Donald
Robertson has actually shown that there
was an even earlier version of this this
French thinker this French psychologist
back in the early 1900s
who's who's showing these interesting
connections and why are people
interested in this well it seems to work
I think most people unless they're doing
it in kind of a boutique way you know a
boutique philosophy I just kind of like
dabble in this they want stuff that
actually does something for them and one
of the cool things about the stoic
literature that we do have because again
we've lost the majority of what was
written in ancient times is that it
contains a lot of useful practices and
principles and perspectives for
reorienting the way that we we do things
reorienting even more importantly the
way that we think about things sort of
taking ownership over our own psyches
and so this is a very important
aspect of it and so this leads us into
these you know five useful practices I I
picked five because that's a nice number
to work with but it could have been ten
practices or 20 practices there's a lot
in in in those and before we do that go
into that though one thing to think
about and maybe we could even have some
open discussion so is is stoicism a good
fit for the the modern workplace
think about it this way what's some of
the stuff that people have to deal with
that they really drives them nuts about
about the workplace today yeah yeah
personality conflicts you could say
that's you know well that ranges from
the mildly irritating to the drives you
totally nuts especially when you know
like it's clearly them that are wrong
what else actually
I'll mention that stoic on I did I let a
workshop and my workshop was
specifically on dealing with difficult
people at work so it was sort of a
subdivision of this but what else about
the workplace besides everybody else in
the workplace
oh yeah especially if you're a larger
organization you're in these business
people all love to talk about innovation
and cutting-edge and and you look at
what they do
mmm it's not always the case all right
especially you know and if you one of
the things I'll mention this total side
note right so I started out as a
traditional academic you know I was a
college professor I started out in a
somewhat strange way teaching in a
maximum-security prison for six years
but then my next job was more or less a
traditional college professor teaching
at a historically black college in the
south and then I left that job where I
was up for early tenure and promotion to
move up to New York but I but I didn't
do it for professional reasons I did it
because my fiancee and I were at that
time doing this long distance
relationship you know North Carolina to
New York is a terrible commute and we
saw we'd only see each other once a
month and we were like this this is
nonsense so I moved up there and I was
still teaching part-time and I had this
very academic mindset like you know what
counts as success is publishing articles
and writing books and going to
conferences and that's where you have
your impact I was already thinking in
terms of how does this have a greater
you know impact in the community or
stuff like that how could this affect my
life other people's lives but I wasn't
doing anything in an entrepreneurial way
my fiancee is very entrepreneurial she's
had businesses she's got that kind of
mindset it took me a long long time to
acquire that that mindset and it was
sort of like kicking and screaming the
whole way now so here's here's where
that's finally gets back to the point
people they asked me well if they
offered you a job at a university you
know a full-time job would you take it
I'm like hell no because I've gotten so
used to not having to ask a chairs
position cheers permission a Dean's
permission a Provost permission to get
to do anything if I want to teach a new
class I create one I don't have to wait
for it to pass through a committee and I
think that's way in a lot of corporate
environments a lot of government
environment
you're always waiting on somebody to
give you the approval for something and
that can that can be very galling
especially when you're like we need to
do this now this is what you know this
is what the best practice would be you
know so that's another sort of broader
thing there's this tendency to get us
I'm going to use I'm just gonna be very
crude about this to sucker us in you
know we're all one big family a
corporation will tell us and what they
mean is we want you to work like in you
know on a family business which means
you don't get paid very much and you put
in a lot of hours but you could say well
I believe in the ethos I believe in what
the company stands for and they can turn
on a dime and do something very
different and you feel a sort of sense
of well why was I doing all of this for
them I mean it's frankly like if modern
stoicism I don't imagine these people
who are involved in it would ever do
this but if the rest of the modern
stoicism team we're all suddenly like
this is wonderful we can make a ton of
money out of this you know I'd get out
of the the team I'd be like well you
guys have lost your way
you know but that's really it's kind of
irritating especially when you've sunk a
lot of your own time and thought and
effort into it it's almost like losing a
relationship for many people losing a
you know moving from one job to another
is almost like a divorce for some people
with the same level of betrayal and all
that sort of stuff what else any other
things that are particularly galling in
the workplace driving you nuts yeah I
think that makes a lot of sense and
there's a tendency these days that's not
going to stop to say well you can do
more with less right we can always be
more and more efficient where as a
society we're kind of on this treadmill
where everybody's encouraged to do a
little
more and then that leads to a little bit
more and a little bit more you know we
don't actually get much more done but
yeah so let's talk about some of some of
the things we can do so before I do that
though how familiar are people with the
Stoics
so I know sort of what audience how many
of you would say that you're like
totally unfamiliar with them you've
heard of them but don't know anything
about them nobody okay so okay what was
one person two people okay how many
would say that you've got some sort of
vague familiarity with them but you
haven't really thought that much about
it maybe you've read you know a post
here there you've read the the
enchiridion or the the the meditations
or or one of the modern stoic books like
William Irvine's guy to the good life or
you know Ryan holidays works or Massimo
Pigliucci is recent very good book how
to be a stoic nobody those few people
okay so how many of you may be very
familiar with the Stoics you've talked
quite a bit about them well we're the
rest of you fit in that didn't raise
your hands okay so so we should have had
more categories that perennial problem
in polling right so okay so that will I
will keep it very basic than I think one
of the things that the Stoics talk about
is the dichotomy of control and it
wasn't called that back then but that's
the way you'll hear about it today
interesting interestingly William Irvine
has proposed a trichotomy of control and
if you if you want to see some sort of
fruitless arguing go on to the stoic
Facebook group and just type in
trichotomy of control and you're gonna
see all these modern Stoics arguing back
and forth whether it's is it a dichotomy
or a trichotomy which is appropriate and
they sometimes get very heated about it
a little on stoic sometimes you know now
the dichotomy of control the way
epictetus articulates it is some things
are in our control and some
things aren't and it's very important
for us to get clear about this because
this is going to have all sorts of other
ramifications so the things that are in
our control like in this passage that
you've got are things like you know our
choice our versions and desires our
thoughts or our judgments in other
places he tells you other things like
our our Faculty of choice you know the
people that we surround ourselves with
sometimes can be a matter of control how
we use things that are outside of our
control can be in our control but many
things are outside of our control and
and when he says this I'll tell you a
little bit about what he means by
control in just a second it's good to
keep in mind that it's a bit more
nuanced than this because that what I'm
going to say is going to be a bit
shocking our bodies are not in our
control when I say that to students are
like wait a second especially these 20
year old students who you know I can go
to the gym or not go to the gym right
and well we'll talk about that in a
minute our money our finances our wealth
is not in our control our reputation is
not in our control
power in position not in our control
other people's thoughts other people's
feelings all of that stuff is outside of
our control just as much as the weather
is outside of our control that's a very
tough doctrine now he doesn't mean that
you can't choose whether you workout or
not or whether you eat crappy food
that's gonna be bad for you or eat good
food that's healthy for you or whether
you engage in personal hygiene or not
he's not crazy right he actually has a
whole chapter in his discourses on
personal personal attractiveness which
covers hygiene and he says stuff like
hey you shouldn't stink right so don't
don't don't tick off the people next to
you because that is in your control
whether you take a bath or not every
once in a while and we're lucky we can
take showers too right so he doesn't
mean that it's it's totally out of our
control in that sense but what he does
mean is that think about this right you
can balance your checkbook you can put
money aside for retirement and we could
have a big collapse and you could lose
it all it is out
out of your control to some degree even
if you plan prudently your body there's
these terrible stories of these people
who are like running and they're in
super great shape and then they keel
over of a heart attack while they're
there running you could also get
yourself in super great shape and then
walk out and get hit by the bus or like
in you know cartoons have a safe fall
hit you on the head all sorts of walking
to and walking along you fall into a man
Hall and the cartoons a they usually
come out of it but if you're a human
real human being and you fall into a
manhole that's pretty much it most
likely because they won't find you for a
while
what else did I mention reputation you
know a great example you can do a lot of
things to manage your reputation but do
you really control it you know I mean
the people who have attempted to often
find out with the the things that they
do to try to control their reputation
how little it is in their control right
as things start to spiral out you know
great example right now Harvey Weinstein
is attempting to do damage control
nobody believes him right nobody's going
to believe him it's not up to him if it
was up to him everyone would believe him
then he's a swell guy and he just made
mistakes we were talking earlier about
planes and and I just heard on the radio
that the the airport cops who pulled
that guy off that United flight they
finally got fired
you know the United tried to do damage
control with that as well then they
remember how the CEO came and gave kind
of a apology that wasn't an apology I'm
sorry that you feel feel that way kind
of apology didn't work at all what say
it again you support of the employees
yeah you know a total digression again
if United was really smart about that
this is a bit more Machiavellian than
stoic to say this they would have thrown
the airport cops under the bus because
it wasn't actually the United employees
who are dragging this poor guy off of
the plane it was the Chicago Airport
police you know but they did somehow
that didn't even though they they're
paid millions of dollars somehow that
didn't occur to the board to come up
with that you know that's interesting to
think about but in any case why does
this matter well Epictetus goes on and
says if you focus on the things that are
outside of your control as if they were
in your control you're gonna be unhappy
you're going to be as he calls it
impeded literally you're gonna have sort
of like shackles put on your legs things
are gonna get in your way you're gonna
get ticked off at people you're gonna
lose your temper
you're gonna blame other people for
things things are not going to go well
if you stick to the things that are
actually in your control which are
largely internal you will actually be
free and so now think about how this
would apply in the workplace one way
that this gets framed in modern stoicism
is we don't really control the outcome
of things we do control the goals that
we set for ourselves the attitudes that
we take the ways that we think about
things so dealing with difficult
co-workers right you can't control them
you may try to generally that backfires
and makes things worse
but you decide how you view them you
decide how you deal with the
interactions they don't have to get to
you that's in some respect up to you
that it's difficult to change that
immediately and we'll talk about why
that that you know why that plays into
things a bit later but if we can apply
this well this distinction between
what's anarchy whole and what's not in
our control we're actually going to be a
lot happier and that has kind of a
feedback effect it changes the ways that
we engage with with other people the
ways that we see the workplace
you know what what do you control in
your workplace for a lot of people it
might be you know if you're in a cubicle
farm you you get to decide what you're
gonna put in that cubicle and that's
about it
all right where are you hitting where do
you hang your jacket or you know what
you're gonna wear some plate well you
have to wear a tie okay you're gonna
wear a fish tie you know we're you know
a fancy tie you know we're really boring
tie and what are you gonna do that's up
to you
what what stoicism Counsel's is focus on
the things that really are up to us and
you're gonna be a lot more you know
well-adjusted in the workplace
and this applies to relationships this
applies to the communities we live in
here's where it gets really interesting
another translation I've talked about
control all this time
the Greek is epic Aman and you kept
ammonia so it could be what's in our
control what's up to us another way of
translating is what's our business some
things are our business other things are
not our business
I remember that you know my my
grandparents are on my mother's side a
french-canadian
and my my grandmother was like straight
out of Quebec and never really spoke
English without too much of an accent
and she also would tell my grandfather
quite often who was kind of a busybody
that things she would say Amy that's not
your business you know and that was the
sort of like the end of it that meant
okay grandma's spoken grandpa now has to
like disengage himself from the
situation and she was giving him a
reminder you know in French would be a
path tone affair right literally it's
not your business that's exactly what
epictetus is talking about he's saying
there's a lot of things that just are
not our business and so we can make a
conscious choice to disengage our our
thoughts you know sort of dwelling on
them our desires and aversions our
emotions from them it's not easy to do
at first but with practice we get better
at it so what might be some obstacles I
mentioned that it takes practice
figuring out what really is in our
control and what's not in our control
that sometimes takes a bit the other
thing is there are certain emotions that
tend to make us more controlling anger
for example when we get angry we often
think that we have more control not only
over ourselves people you're out of
control no I'm not I know exactly what
I'm doing but we also think that somehow
the things that we do can change the
situation in a productive way right
the thing about driving right by driving
here is kind of frustrating we were all
talking about Chicago traffic and I
wanted to get here right when we get
here at four o'clock what time do I get
here around 4:45 right now 15 minutes of
that was me leaving a bit late but the
rest of it
stupid Chicago drivers all those other
people all of whom are essentially same
as me trying to do the same thing right
and I'm not a great person when it comes
to developing these things but I did
manage to get here without honking my
horn all right now what would honking
the horn accomplished would it make any
of those people move any faster know
what we hunt the horn because we get
angry and we're like dammit get moving
you know as if somehow it's gonna change
the situation if that's out of my
control once once you get on the road so
many things are outside of your control
what you do have control over is your
own attitudes and your own thoughts and
your you know what you do with them so
the workplace is like that too so what
you know let's let's talk for a few
minutes and we can do more in the Q&A
later does this make sense to you and
you see problems with this this is
something where you're like that's never
gonna work for me yeah did you if you
don't have any elbows move on to the
next one because we have four more to go
and I'll even throw in a bonus one if we
have enough time that I think it's kind
of cool so negative visualization how
many of you have heard of this no nobody
well you you must have heard of the
Tatia Melora that right no so negative
negative visualization is William
Irvine's term for it's a good one it's a
it's an old stoic practice it's not
unique to the stocks others have done
this as well
premeditation of bad things or of
adversity thinking about them in advance
and you notice some of these quotes like
epictetus says hey you don't think about
death every day let death and exile and
all the things which appear terrible
daily be before your eyes but chiefly
death and you will you will win never
enter you will never entertain any
abject thought nor too eagerly covet
anything why it puts things in
perspective now I'm not saying you have
to think about death every day alright
and in the workplace right I don't know
that that's that's so helpful but think
about the the stuff that you're gonna
encounter Marcus Aurelius has this
wonderful passage where he's talking to
himself and this is part of his daily
practice and it for it is from many
Stoics when you wake up in the morning
think to yourself I'm gonna meet all
these kinds of people and they're all
awful and you know they're translated
different it's the busybody the meddler
the rude the greedy you know and he's
not saying any of these people are good
people or we're gonna reframe it so
somehow they're they're all you know
swell he's saying you're gonna meet a
lot of jerks now imagine you're like in
customer service this applies to you
completely right or if you're in the
retail industry or if you've got a jerk
who's a boss or jerk co-workers now why
would you want to think about that ahead
of time wouldn't it be better not to
think about that and just face it when
you deal with them so if you think about
it ahead of time you're doing it in a
controlled environment where you
actually can do something about it and
this is something where the cognitive
behavior therapy is actually like shown
that you know you know if you do it in a
relaxed environment you can reduce your
aversion to certain things it's great
for dealing with phobias as well but the
Stoics were doing this you know 2,000
years before that and they would you
know how would it work you you
do it in a just sort of general way when
you wake up in the morning think about
the things that you're going to face and
there's a couple aspects to this there's
it's not dwelling at it so that you can
feel bad about it it's not dwelling on
it so you can have a daily cry about how
crap your life has something like that
and it's not to be morbid right it's
rather to think about well this is the
stuff that could happen how bad would it
be is it something I could actually
handle the
epictetus says when you encounter
something difficult think about what
resources you have for dealing with it
and if you do that when you actually get
into the bad situation it turns out to
be not as bad as you expected even if it
is bad stuff that you're going through
like I used this for I a root canal last
week and I used this for thinking about
you know I was not happy about it
you know the doctor the dentist was
assuring me it's nothing like the old
days you know we're gonna get Len T of
painkillers and all that and my last
dental thing that I'd had was was over
20 years ago when they took my wisdom
teeth out with minimal minimal numbing
and the guy putting his foot on my
shoulder and wrenching the teeth out of
my mouth I went into that office
actually things would be put under and
they were like insurance doesn't cover
it so this is what insurance will cover
and then of course you know they they
stitched me up and and when I got home
immediately the stitches like came
undone and I'm on my own with like a
mouthful of blood trying to communicate
with the the nurse who of course
couldn't understand me so the terrible
experience so I'm thinking this is gonna
suck you know but I you know did my sort
of thinking about well what is it what
is it gonna be like and you've got to be
sort of realistic with yourself this is
not the same thing as getting teeth
pulled out of you
they're just drilling you know they're
going to give you some some stuff and
even if it hurts a bit you can probably
take it you know you're up to this
people go through much worse things
you've actually had worse pains than
that you you sort of think yourself
through it it's not a guarantee that
it's always going to go well right but
if you do it ahead of time you're
probably going to be a lot better off
and if you make it a daily practice
which the Stoics do imagine how this
could work out for you in the workplace
do you think it would be helpful not
well you can do both of them together
yeah I mean you do control some aspects
like with the wisdom tooth thing all
right I could say well I can take the
attitude this is horrible this is you
know my whole day is gonna suck
and then actually went out a lot longer
than it then then it was expected to
supposed to be like a 1 and a half hour
procedure he was the only dentist there
that morning so he had to go like go off
to other patients and he'd come back to
me it took three hours they had to shoot
some more stuff in because I started
actually feeling what they were doing
yeah
it was part of that process and part of
that experience is just saying I'm gonna
suck this experience for whatever it is
whatever it is yeah
is that is that part is it those can
work in yeah they can work in tandem all
right yeah yeah and you know as Joe was
pointing out stoicism is a system so
you've got a whole bunch of it one of
the people that I that I saw talked
about this at Stough account X was using
it talking about like a web I think it's
a great metaphor a web is a whole bunch
of different parts all connected with
each other we learn them one at a time
and we practice them one at a time but
they are really all interconnected so
yeah well let's talk about dealing with
appearances and and holding back assent
then so appearances is a technical term
that I think Jill's going to talk about
next next in the next talk right so it's
Fantasia and Greek and it gets
translated as appearance or impression
and depending on the translation that
you've got another way of translating it
is
imagination and we're constantly
bombarded with the world telling us
things are this way things are this way
things are this way right and we also
live in a world that's supersaturated
with media where it's already being
framed like that as well so we have a
even more difficult thing to deal with
the Stoics say you actually should treat
appearances as appearances don't give
assent to them don't say they are
exactly what they appear to be so
Epictetus says
harsh appearance presents itself - you
tell yourself hey that's just only an
appearance not what it appears to be it
could be what it appears to be right
sometimes the guy who's mugging you is
actually mugging you right or sometimes
the co-worker who appears to be a jerk
really is a jerk you know or you know we
could go on and on and on withwith
things like that but a lot of times
they're they're not and we engage in
automatic thinking we we jump to
conclusions about things where we
shouldn't draw those those conclusions
so quickly and we have emotional
reactions based on that so if we can
take a pause and this is what the Stoics
suggests you know you're confronted with
something just back up from it for a
second and think it is are things this
way I know I'm starting to already react
is this the best thing for me to do you
know I mean think about the things that
bother you at work where maybe maybe
you've got it wrong any you know any
examples I mean for me it's personality
conflicts I mean I got into stoicism in
part because I was interested in anger
management why was i interested in anger
management because I needed anger
management right and philosophy helped
me with that so you know what what does
an angry person do people are jerks they
have it in for me
they shouldn't treat me that way anger
also like sees insults where they didn't
actually happen you know maybe that's
you know reading too much into the
situation what happens in your
workplaces where you've gotten some
things wrong
we're gonna give you gentlemen
generalities and then I'll think that
somebody's attacking ya or you know I
want to do my I always want to do my
best job at work I was wanting
everything to be perfect and sometimes
I'll take a constructive criticism what
somebody else might notice is 'm as a
personal attack thank you personally
yeah I think like they're trying to take
you down a peg or compete with you or
yeah and and you know it's sometimes
really not about sometimes they are but
but sometimes they're wrong about you
goes in the way of people reactions
that's a great example yeah there's so
many there's so many times where it has
nothing to do with what's going on with
us it has to do with something in their
home life or they're distracted or yeah
that there's there's a lot of people who
sort of think that and it's not a fun
feeling to feel like somehow they
they're the center of attention and they
don't want to be right and everybody's
reacting to them it's so liberating to
find out that nobody's actually paying
any attention to what you're doing you
know so so yeah buta says this nice
phrase here he says remember that not
the person who gives ill language or a
blow insults but the judgment which
represents these things is insulting so
when somebody provokes you be assured
that it's your own opinion that provokes
you so don't be hurried with the
appearance give it a little bit of time
and you know it may turn out to be that
things are the way that they appear or
it may turn out not to be the case this
is this taking a pause now that's a
volitional thing you have to choose to
do that before it becomes sort of a
habit you have to you have to go against
your natural tendency which is to let
your thoughts run away with you
but if you do it long enough then it
gets a bit easier so
any plots or things or questions that we
should hit on with that yeah no no I
absolutely yeah we were talking about a
little bit earlier that I had to stow
some of the same reasons that you did Oh
anger management yeah other Terrorizer
though boots say do things that were
destructive for the relationship either
that's why I'm doing that we would step
back we were like I don't want to be
saying those things so we should abuse
again for her yeah and so one of the big
things that I got a this dozen for was
learning to respond rather than react
and I think that's a good distinction
yeah that reaction a reaction is
emotional and I myself feel those
emotions gonna try to suppress those
emotions I want to be able to take it
know that I'm feeling it yeah take a
pause like you said and then respond in
a way that's pretty productive for us
rather than contribute to yeah I mean
the Stoics say we're rational beings
we're not rational in the sense that
we're rational all the time we have to
choose to actually be rational in
situations like that and that's also
exercise in terms of the virtues that's
exercised in the venture prudence
well temperance to some degree also
sometimes courage interestingly enough
because courage means us not just you
know like getting out on the battlefield
and being there with your shield and
spear and all that it means proceeding
through what's difficult sticking to
what what's difficult because we know
what's the right thing and saying you're
sorry in an argument where you don't
really feel like you're the one who's
wrong but you know that it's gonna be
the helpful thing to say at that point
to defuse it that's tough to do if
you're somebody like us I guess
like yes yes any other day that's
erections this morning where she said
she doesn't like using the word sorry
because it feels negative so she would
rather use I apologize or some other
some other term and I said as long as
you take ownership over it yeah how you
admit that you're taking ownership over
your flaw or over the situation how you
word it really isn't as important as
yeah it's interesting I mean in terms of
like philosophy of communication we make
a distinction between performative
speech acts and you know other types of
speech acts and they've described in
different ways so I'm sorry is sort of
describing your state of mind right it's
not a performative act saying I'm
apologizing to you is a performative act
you're doing you're doing the very thing
sort of like saying it when I I promised
you that's another performative act you
know yeah so that's that's that's a
that's a good one
yeah I had an experience with a boss who
was very negative sort of me in
microphone I'll and so he wasn't letting
up and because I have a non
confrontational personality I didn't say
anything
yeah when I should have because then I
started brewing over in my mind
constantly you internalized what he is
saying right right yeah instead of
communicating yeah that I don't feel
that my performance is that way I have a
feel better about this because then I
wouldn't have been brooding over it for
the next four hours and being so angry
yeah so I think I guess I'm sort of
reacting negatively with whatever's
going on it's also okay to just voice
what you're thinking and yeah absolutely
I water yeah that person might be
horrible or in continue
to be unfair or in which case you know
what's going on in their mind anyway
yeah and and it but it can be you know
there's there's temperament involved
like somebody like me I don't have a
problem with it what I have a problem
with is being too assertive right where
it becomes aggressive other people are
more you know you might say conflict
averse right and so we have to we have
to figure out what are what our
temperaments are and sometimes go
against it in that way where you make a
choice and it's a hard choice to make so
that would be using the virtue of
courage and and the other thing is yeah
you can talk with them and I think from
a stoic perspective that's a great idea
and then they would say realize that the
other person's reaction totally out of
your control socrates who have a pic
tedious looked at is like you know he's
though he talked about him more than he
does ii know or anybody else that's the
person that that
Epictetus talks about the most in all of
his works he says socrates only reached
1 in a thousand people when he went
around and was saying hey you should you
like fix your life you know or hey
you're you're kind of screwing things up
only about one in a thousand or two
actually listen to him but socrates kept
on doing it anyway because he wasn't he
realized it was the right thing to do
was to say something but he had no
control over the outcome that's up to
the other person so you know I think
that would apply to a boss like that you
may you may not ever get through to them
interestingly though if you do get so
with some of them if you give some push
back suddenly they there's no like oh no
I'm gonna now I'm gonna pay attention
and take this person seriously who I've
been taking for granted you know I once
had a a book that was had been a
committee decided wouldn't be published
I fired off an angry email about why
each of the committee members reports
were wrong to the to the acquisition
editor and I didn't put any like screw
you or stuff like that in there I wasn't
totally burning bridges because I like
the guy if I didn't like him quite
frankly I probably would have thrown
some of those in
the book ended up getting published in
part because the editor was like well
maybe these criticisms that you have of
their criticisms are actually on point
let's convene another committee and then
the other committee was like yeah of
course these were totally off-base
and it was that reaction but I see I
don't have any problems right well I
have to watch the other side which is
going too far with it I've done a few of
those emails in my life too you know
terrible yeah so this is actually a good
segue into understanding the actions and
the motivations of other so one of the
things that the Stoics counseled us to
do is realize that the reason why people
behave the way that they do is because
they think that's that's appropriate or
that's the right thing even when they're
saying I'm going to do the wrong thing
deliberately on a higher level they're
thinking that's the way I should behave
and that can change right that's not
something that's absolutely guaranteed
to stay that way but they have to
actually choose to change it and you've
probably all heard this in psychotherapy
the other person has to want to change
the Stoics are totally on board with
that
the Stoics would also say that when
people are bad to us or bad to other
people it's because they're deluded
about the nature of the good or the
nature of what's rational or what's
appropriate to human beings and they're
going to keep on acting that way and so
to expect them to do something different
is is really unrealistic and is laying
on it's trying to control over something
that we don't control right what can our
attitude be instead now this is not what
Epictetus says but I'm going to
paraphrase it you could say you poor
bastard and not in a patronizing way
where you're like you know or
passive-aggressive but realize that like
when somebody does something that ticks
you off or that makes you feel sad or or
anxious that they're they're not doing
it just because they want to stick it to
you and they may in fact want it to
intimidate you or something like that
but they're doing it because they think
that's the right thing to do
and they are fundamentally hurting
themselves they are out of touch with
what genuine human nature would would
would say they ought to be doing they're
out of - they think they're rational
they're irrational they think they're in
touch with the good they're out of touch
with it and so what could our response
to being said advocacy it says in
another place you know you don't
actually have to have any response to
them other than registering they're
actually off base but the other possible
thing is says if you're going to feel
anything instead of feeling anger why
not feel what we translate as pity Alejo
in Greek which I think today we could
translate as compassion why not feel
compassionate towards them that's where
you know there's there's I guess a
couple ways that you can say you poor
bastard to somebody you can say it in a
very demeaning way or you can say like
oh you you know you could say you poor
schmuck you don't know any better you
know now you don't have to actually tell
the person that and I don't suggest
doing that with your co-workers that you
think are out facing I understand the
good that's not going to help things at
all but that's something you can say to
yourself and that will take some of the
sting out of it and now notice what this
doesn't require it doesn't require
forgiving it doesn't require forgetting
and it doesn't require excusing they're
still doing something wrong going back
to that Marquez quote he doesn't say
yeah you know there's a bunch of people
you're gonna encounter today and they're
you know they're greedy they kind of
appear to be greedy but they're not
really greedy no they're greedy you're
gonna run into them and they're they're
mistaken and and their understanding of
the good and those poor bastards can't
can't really see it otherwise they could
if somebody led them to it and the other
thing that goes along with this with the
Stoics is hey if you want to make a
difference try to show them that they've
got things wrong but realize that again
when that one in a thousand thing most
of the time people don't don't respond
to that they find some way that you're
totally wrong you know would this be
helpful for you dealing with co-workers
or bosses yeah go ahead
in so the girlfriend that we've broken
up but we've stayed friends and whatnot
I've got a couple other people kind of
kind of friends who push buttons and
they like I just just to do it just it
just to be sure yeah guys kind of do
that jacking with them with each other
to my practice now is when they start
doing that like are you okay in a bad
day oh yeah yeah yeah no I was like this
isn't how we should be this isn't how
this isn't okay this isn't normal
yeah like what's going on so I'm up yeah
you're reacted like your reaction or
you're attacking me is in no way normal
for the discourse we've been having yeah
yeah that's anyways thank me so we're
you mentioned compassion you know I
started after one of his big things is
compassionate yes is all about like love
and compassion just a lot of people
wouldn't know that you're there for them
I didn't see for understand angles every
action yeah and notice a longer
compassion or however we want to frame
it doesn't require us to think that
people are better than they are you know
and as a matter of fact the the fact
that you can love somebody being as
screwed up as they are you know and then
we can also turn it on ourselves to you
you should also be compassionate with
yourself the Stoics thing because you're
gonna screw up all the time especially
we started out you know so Seneca
councils being being compassionate
towards your own self as well there was
one on the oh yeah I was going to tell
you about another technique that kind of
fits into this bill revine calls an
insult pacifism how to deal with people
who are insulting to you he actually had
a colleague who came up to him he writes
about this in his book
I think it's an in his is a guide to the
stoic life but it's also in his recent
book on insults he had a colleague who
came up to him and he said I don't know
whether you're you're simply you know
ignorant or whether you're evil and Bill
Irvine said why not both
and so it's funny right and it doing
that sort of thing humor actually does
defuse situations sometimes not actually
the source of the ear sight to it could
be done in a funny way you know Oh get
dropped on your head
you know what's wrong with you yeah and
so humour can sometimes be be useful and
especially self-deprecating humor
Epictetus says that you know somebody
says to him hey you're a terrible guy
for these reasons wow you don't really
know me because if you did you would
have had this reason and this reason and
this reason as well and we I think we
all have enough material for those sorts
of routines right I know I I mean the
older we get the more we have I think -
all right so all right the last one I
wanted to talk about picking up the
right handle in the present here I'm
kind of smashing together couple stoic
ideas he's got this great quote right I
think many of you have probably seen
this everything has two handles the one
which it may by which it may be carried
the other by which it cannot so you've
got something you can pick it up this
way and you can carry it along this one
you can pick it up but you can't carry
it so he's got the example your brothers
mean to you if your brother acts on
justly don't lay hold on the action by
the handle of his injustice for by that
it cannot be carried you're gonna be
really ticked off and hurt and and
you're gonna carry around like you carry
a grudge but by the opposite he's your
brother he was brought up with you and
thus you will lay hold on it as it is to
be carried what he's talking about here
is selective attention he's talking
about situations that are complex where
they can be interpreted in multiple ways
he's not saying don't interpret it at
all that your brother's jerk your
brother is a jerk but that's not all
there is in the situation you can look
on the other things and that's a choice
that we can we can make and choosing to
see things that way will in fact free us
and make us less irritated and
potentially even more happy now what I
wanted to sort of draw that out further
into with this other quote he talks
about he's talking to somebody saying
hey look you've studied all this stomach
stuff
what are you waiting for why haven't you
actually done done what you're supposed
to do with it
and he says this instant think of
yourselves worthy of living as a mature
person and one making progress
and here's where it gets really
interesting now is the combat now the
Olympiad comes on nor can it be put be
put off by once being defeated in giving
way proficiency is lost or by the
contrary preserved meaning that every
moment that we're in where we have to
make a decision about these sorts of
things the stakes are bigger than just
at that moment the Stoics are great
believers in the force of habit what we
are the way that we react the way our
thoughts lead to emotions is largely the
product certainly at this point in our
lives of habits that we've built up over
time some of them are good some of them
are bad and the bad ones take a lot of
retraining to get ourselves away from
epictetus says if you want to change
your habits you have to you know push
yourself over to the other side and do
things that feel very unnatural to you
until it eventually comes back to where
it should be and you know you just
talked about anger and particularly says
if you manage to go one day without
anger that's that's nice three days
that's great to manage to go thirty days
without losing your temper sacrifice to
God because now you've really made it
I've never made it more than like three
days myself but you know keeping track
of that sort of stuff paying attention
to how the immediate moment and the
choices that you make about how to
construe it feed into your habits your
habits not only of acting but your
habits of having certain emotional
reactions your habits of having thoughts
that come to mind another great example
from from anger right they tell you feel
angry go take a walk that's not by
itself necessarily productive because if
you're walking along and you're thinking
about that son of a [ __ ] you know I
here's what I'd love to say to them well
you're gonna come back even angrier but
if you deliberately say alright what can
i how can I you know get myself what I
want to do in this situations not feel
so upset let me think about something
else maybe I'm going to deliberately
choose to look at the trees and count
the birds that I see
or something like that then you stop
being angry because now you're paying
attention to birds and birds don't take
you off unless you've got some we heard
fixation on birds right and you can do
all sorts of things like that so in a
way we could think of these two things
as being connected the importance of the
the the immediate situation for feeding
into our habits and picking things up by
the right handle in the workplace we're
presented with these sorts of things all
the time and again in in relationships
and in dealing with other people in
politics social media you know so social
media gives you a lot of great
how does he mean that thing that he
wrote just there you know well you can
pick it up by this handle pick it up by
this handle right social media is really
interesting and video games are really
interesting because if you think about
habit formation you can you know it
takes a lot of actions repetition to
build or to break a habit play a video
game you can be engaging in thousands of
actions within the space of a couple
hours you know and if it's designed
certain ways it can have cognitive
aspects and emotive aspects same thing
with engaging on social media you know
if you wanted to be a troll right you
just blaze away
typing stuff constantly for three hours
free time and you could fairly quickly
start to reinforce bad habits but you
could also do that with weaning yourself
away from bad habits or developing good
habits one of the good habits might be
I'm not going to comment on this because
this isn't my business you know and if
you want a place to do that might I
suggest going to the stoicism group
because with 30,000 members you're
guaranteed to see somebody posting
something or commenting something that
you can disagree with and say this
person is stupid
you know what the hell are they doing
there's all these things you know people
put is is is you know they'll put
something crazy up is this a stoic is
this a stoic thing and then other people
way in no it isn't you dummy you know
that's not very stoic either right so
maybe not commenting could be a thing to
do you know reading reading it with and
just lurking you know for those who are
perennial lurkers may be saying
something every once in a while that
might be the the change as well but we
can say this with all sorts of things
there's a swing back to the workplace
again is this the sort of thing that you
can apply in the workplace so it's your
workplace or not what do you think
whether you get the two handles right
situations are you going to choose which
one you're going to pick it up by like
what what would be company memos a great
example of an opportunity for that
they're usually written in kind of
ham-fisted ways you know you'd be like
why is this person in charge it's sure
they sure can't write well I should be
in charge you know that's not a handle
you're gonna be able to carry it by very
long you know maybe you should actually
be in charge but that's still not the
handle you can you can carry it by
probably the handle of where you like
correct it and send it back in a copy
all is not the handle it's a grasp it by
you better well they think about that
too whether they're probably our handles
care about why you react a certain way
like you read yeah because we're all a
raw product you said we're on fire like
our personalities are based on all
experiences rice we're all from
different backgrounds of all different
expenses our reaction is based on God
that feels familiar and that happened
last time it was uncomfortable or
whatever so is it is it helpful to go
back and understand why we're here act a
certain way
absolu Asst yeah not encourage
understanding why we tend to react a
certain way yeah self-knowledge yeah
yeah I mean there's two things to say
about that one is that you could think
of the Stoics and not just the Stoics
but many other great traditions of
philosophy as saying that much of the
time we are we're operating in a in a
deterministic way where we're not
operating with with freedom we're
reacting in certain ways and it often
looks you know quite complex and we can
come up with great rationalizing stories
afterwards now it's not always like that
because we do have a scope of some
degree of freedom the the epictetus
calls that your prior ASIS your Faculty
of choice right and he says it's so free
that not even God could compel it and
yet most of the time we choose those
words gonna sound kind of existentialist
we choose to give that freedom away and
not to use that and we choose to let let
things go and kind of go in an automatic
fashion now we can we can choose to do
differently and it's very hard at first
but we can slowly expand that sphere of
freedom to where we're never like
totally free right and I'm always gonna
have to deal with having a temperament
that steers me towards towards anger and
competitiveness in a way that you don't
right we we have different temperaments
that way and there could be two is that
net a because that environment there's
all sorts of interesting things that we
get into here's the other thing I want
to say Cicero in on duties where he's
telling us about what the great stoic
philosopher who we don't have anything
by Penn 80s had said about these things
so that each of us has four characters
one character we may not even really
call it character persona
it's just universal human nature that's
the same in all of us
it gives us some basic guidelines sort
of some
might say the hardware that we all have
by which we work the second is our
temperament and our temperaments are
different and they could be a product of
environment they could be a product of
genetics I mean I I recently got in
touch with my birth father and I've got
two half-siblings and we all have a lot
of similarities a lot of behavioral
similarities and we grew up in very
different places so that can be part of
it even to the point that we all went
into the army we all did you know
martial arts we all enjoyed reading we
all fenced which is kind of a strange
thing to get into so there the
temperament plays a role and Cicero says
we should actually make sure to
cultivate what are what it what gifts
we've been given so long as they don't
contradict that universal human nature
so not like hey I'm I'm gonna be the
best killer in the world know that that
that doesn't count but you know if
you're particularly musical yeah
cultivate that right the third is that
which circumstances force on us some
people you know get very adverse
circumstances some people grow up in
very nice circumstances things like the
amount of wealth that you have you know
what political power you're given
reputation all those sorts of things
Cicero says a lot of that's really a
matter of fortune or chance and what we
happen to get a lot of us like to take
credit for the good stuff and this with
all the bad stuff but really a lot of
that you know other processes working so
that's three so far right what's the
fourth that which we freely choose so
that means what we do with all this
other stuff what we make of ourselves
given that you know when it comes to
like the nature versus nurture thing
with that psychologists love to go round
and round around about I always say well
you're leaving out you know free will
obviously because it doesn't fit into
this is any sort of scientific schema
but that's just as important what do we
do with nature what do we do with
nurture because not everybody turns out
the same way and to some degree if we
become conscious of this we can
make choices and so to go back to this
you know if we if we're totally unaware
about the fact that we actually do make
choices even if they're just little ones
you know we're it we're screwed we can't
we can't get ourselves out of that that
cycle if we realize that we have some
measure even if it's a small measure of
control and we can intervene at least in
our own thought processes or our
feelings then we can start slowly
ratcheting it open by the way that we
change our habits and this is what the
stoic philosophy is intended to do and
now the workplace a lot of it is matters
that are externals things that are
outside of our control so you might say
well how does this actually get us there
the Stoics thought that even the things
that are outside of your control you at
least have the choice about how you
react to them how you deal with them or
use them that's a way of translating the
Greek word crisis or faith I literally
to use but it also means how we deal
with stuff so my coworker is never
getting their work done and that's
impacting my ability to write my reports
that I it is a I can't get them to do it
even though I've yelled at them and you
know sent nasty emails and stuff like
that and I can't get them fired so
they're gonna keep on doing that sort of
thing and I can't get myself on a
different team but I can actually decide
how I'm going to view it how I'm gonna
react to them how I'm gonna treat them
that is within my my control and whether
I let let it get to me or not that that
is up to me and is really my business
you know so yeah to go back to that
question all these kind of inner
interconnects with each other I think
yeah a long answer to a short question
but sometimes I got to get the question
to answer ratio a little bit more
compressed I think so there for me to
work out you know
the return question yeah that sounds
good
you